Justice League has arrived and finally
United six of DC Comics flagship heroes
only together can they fight off an
invasion of violent parademons from the
alien world of apocalypse and the evil
mother box machinations of dark sides
creepy uncle woven into the film's
half-dozen converging storylines we're
also a whole lot of little Easter eggs
that called out to the Justice League's
rich comic book and movie history here
are just a few party like it's 1989 for
many Batman fans the golden era of DC
movies began and ended with 1989 s
Batman directed by Tim Burton and score
by New Wave virtuoso and cinematic
composer Danny Elfman Elfman stepped
away from the whole Batman thing after
1992 s Batman Returns leaving five
indelible notes stuck in every Batman
fans head forever it took 25 years but
Elfman returned to score Justice League
and he brought his old soundtrack with
him as Batman appears in front of
Commissioner Gordon on the rooftops of
Gotham City those five notes can be
heard again and it's pretty sweet the
penguin even though Batman is usually
only ever seen fighting street toughs
Superman and demon bugs from space the
DC EU drops hints about his 20 years of
crime fighting in Gotham from the
spray-painted Robin suit in his Batcave
- casual mentions of his past adventures
one especially great mention comes when
Alfred drops a bomb about exploding
wind-up penguins which can only mean one
thing it's hard to imagine when a DC EU
penguin would look like but he'll
probably have a lot of tattoos daddy
issues and an incomprehensible backstory
whatever happens the DC EU needs to
bring back the bomb birds in Janus we
also get a hint at another Batman
villain who goes by the name of black
mask as Batman battles a para demon
across the skies of Gotham we see a
bunch of different buildings and one of
them bears a large sign that says Janus
the name refers to a few things in the
DC Universe but the most likely use here
is Janus cosmetics a company once run by
the psychotic black mask Wayne
Enterprises ends up purchasing Janus
cosmetics and leaving Roman without a
job which causes the murderous magnate
to take on the villainous mantle of
black mask and swear revenge on Bruce
Wayne at least
not kite man right Green Lantern the
schedule for the DC movie universe has
changed shaped more times than plastic
band but one thing that's been more or
less consistent is that the DC EU would
include the Green Lantern Corps in one
way or another as of now they'll be
getting their own movie in 2020 but no
one really expected to see a lantern in
Justice League still at least one of the
dudes appears during the historic battle
between the armies of apocalypse and the
collected might of Earth's heroes it's a
quick shout-out to future DC EU films
and places the Corps on earth at least
once during their billion year history
patrolling the cosmos for bad business
New Gods
leave it to horn-headed villain
Steppenwolf to literally drop the name
of his first appearance comic in one of
his many speeches about how the old gods
are just a bunch of dead losers so it's
up to the new gods to set the universe
up right of course Steppenwolf first
appeared in New Gods number 7 so the guy
is anything but subtle the phrase New
Gods refers to the entire pantheon of
heroes and villains devised by Jack
Kirby a bunch of super powerful aliens
who split the residents between the
warring worlds of New Genesis and
apocalypse just how many of these
weirdos will appear in the DC EU is
anyone's guess but if DC knows what's
good for them we'll be seeing granny
goodness next right Superman vs flash
who's faster the flash master of the
Speed Force or Superman the alien who
can do just about anything except carry
a playable video game the two heroes
comparable speed is glimpse briefly
during the final fight against
Steppenwolf but Justice League's
mid-credits scene is a direct tribute to
the many many times that Superman and
flash engage in a friendly competition
to see who was fastest who wins you'll
just have to check out Superman issue
number 199 to find out or flash issue
number 175 or Adventures of Superman
issue number 463 or at dozen other
comics that apparently never
definitively settled the score aren't
there people who need saving somewhere
too many leagues by the end of Justice
League both Bruce Wayne and Lex Luthor
are putting together their teams while
neither one is outright named the
implications are obvious Bruce is making
plans to set up a table with six chairs
or maybe more Bruce
Hideout can only mean one thing the hall
pretty consistently features a table at
which all the members of the league make
all the big decisions like how they're
gonna beat the newest evil or if they
should order from Quiznos or Subway
something tough choice meanwhile an
escape Lex Luthor talks about forming
his own league which can only be the
injustice league the group of villains
was founded by Lex Luthor at one point
the team counted Deathstroke who makes a
Justice League cameo as one of its
members at least 60 villains have cycled
through the injustice league but a few
are already in the DC EU was that thief
being apprehended by Wonder Woman at the
end of the film possibly Selina Kyle
Black Manta is scheduled to be a villain
in Aquaman's solo film and half of the
Suicide Squad if it members so that's a
good chunk of the injustice league right
there truth and justice even the most
casual fans of Superman know that the
Big Blue Boy Scout stands for three main
ideals really old fans of Superman know
that back in the 1940s Fleischer Studios
Superman was only really into those
first two ideals Superman fights a
never-ending battle for truth and
justice but the time the 1952
live-action TV series came around
Superman was in to the American Way as
well the slogan even appears in 1978
Superman I'm here to fight for truth and
justice in the American Way and of
course it even made an appearance in
Justice League during Superman's fight
with Steppenwolf when our reborn hero
declares that in addition to truth
he's also kinda into justice as well now
good for him the original Jimmy Olsen
it's probably the most subtle Easter Egg
in all of Justice League but it's a good
one most people probably won't recognize
the officer who checks Barry Allen into
the prison to see his dad but the actors
name is Mark McClure you may recognize
him as Marty McFly's older brother Dave
or well I was blown away when my dentist
told me I had turned her aside from that
McClure's most prominent role was as
news boy Jimmy Olsen and all for
Christopher Reeves Superman films and
even the wildly unpopular 1984 Supergirl
movie making him the only actor to
appear in more Superman films than
Christopher Reeve himself Congrats on
number 6 mark the
for watching flip the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Applause]
[Music]